how often have you heard experts and
politicians talk about the fact that AI
and automation could be the biggest
threat to society how often have you
heard that now here's a reality of it
there is a community that's gonna pay a
big price for automation and AI and I'll
get into that community here in a minute
but let me give you complete different
perspective about automation AI what if
I told you automation and AI has given
us thousands of hours back to do
whatever we want to do with our lives or
what do you mean Pat let me explain
there used to be a time we would spend
Sunday's putting our albums together and
we go take the pictures then go to
Costco or old work whatever store you
would go to printer pictures come back
buy a couple albums spend hours putting
it together then remember when the
albums would tear you will need to put
the tape over it and then the kid tears
your pictures you got to go back you can
drive oh my gosh I don't want to do this
again or how about writing letters
member writing letters you would write a
letter to somebody and then you really
wanted to say what was on your mind a
like oh no I don't like this then you
would have to erase it and you're like I
wrote a page and a half thing you would
have to tear it apart rewrite it you
don't want them to see that you erase
because the word can be read any have to
do that again and then you have to go
drive around the community where these
blue boxes that oh my gosh where's the
mailbox at and then you would get out of
the car in the rain drop it in the box
and and get back and finally a week
later gets out there right today what do
you do you text you email you don't like
a sentence you just go back and then you
sent second later the person has it it
can think about it get back people oh my
gosh I'm heartfelt thank you for this
message gym membership cancellations you
have to send it in and Jim's would
always say oh we didn't really receive
your letter of cancel yes you did no we
never received your letter of
cancellation nowadays you go online you
unsubscribe you cancel whatever you want
to do right automation automation is
giving us so much now let's go let's go
worse kissing automation because back in
the days even TV is automation we have
to get out of the car
great-grandparents had to go to place to
drive you know you didn't have AC or
heater back in the days and you go to
place and you get entertained now you
sit in your room watch a show from the
comfort of your bed from your living
room you can Netflix and chill all you
want if you chill in public they're
gonna put you in prison you're being
entertained that's automation how much
time did I give you to you and your girl
who you and your boyfriend you your
husband wife how much more
it's automation but here's the thing
let's go to automation today with cars
oh my gosh hey what if what if we're not
gonna drive cars in about people you
know cars are automating they take us
places planes trains a lot of things
have been automated for a long time
we're not panicking about the book cars
we are he was the best thing about cars
being automated what is it Pat let me
explain if cars are automated say you
drive an hour a day say that's 400 hours
a year right now when you're driving
what are you doing you're driving
hopefully you're paying attention maybe
you can respond to a text or two when
you're out of red light but you can't
really be doing a lot of different
things right okay now let's say
automations here with cars you don't
have to drive anymore you put an address
it takes you there right gives your
phone at hours per year here's the real
question with automation why I tell you
nothing is new what are we going to do
with that 400 hours that's given back to
us uh-huh what do you mean by that
here's what I mean by that we can easily
use that 400 hours to watch more TV on
our farm we came to cell phone and hours
to follow more sports on our phone we
can except play games on our phone we
can use that for no darts to just look
at everybody's newsfeed on our phone we
keys all that stuff or we can use that
400 hours to buy a master class to watch
a YouTube channel that's gonna teach you
some stuff to read articles to do
research to take a new course to study
to get smarter to read books to listen
to audio books we can do that so the
challenge is not automation the
challenge isn't air because the reality
of it is automation and AI is gonna make
it so easy to create wealth look how
many rags to riches stories you're gonna
see the next 10 to 20 years but do you
want to know why politicians don't talk
about the habits of people because they
lose voters that's what they do say they
don't want to talk about the habits of
people because of people gonna say I
don't like that guy he he called me lazy
that I don't work I don't like that guy
so what if I wanna watch TV while the
car is driving I want to entertain
myself it's better to be healthy why
should I always be working on that
telling to always be working all I'm
telling you is politicians are selling
you what you want to hear not what we
want we need to hear unfortunately the
same people they're talking to other
people they're hurting the most it's so
wild
we are so naive and we fall for this
stuff because they're just wanting votes
they just want to make sure they become
presidents that's what they want how
often do you think they're gonna get out
and actually give an action plan that's
us having to change about ourselves it's
us you know it's us moving Steve and I
Smith's mother asked him what could you
have done differently not what society
could have done differently and you go
back and look at people who ended up
doing something very big with their
lives they took responsibility they what
can I do differently what happens can
you change what happens can I change I
had terrible habits I had to change the
habits it wasn't society's fault it
wasn't my parents fault it wasn't my
friends fault I control my decisions I
am free you are free see I believe in
the betterment of people I believe
you're capable
I believe deep down inside you want to
go out there and do something big with
your life so you own it so people say
you did it you found a group of people
you got to work you became a good boss
you became a good leader that people
wanted to be around you for a while and
guess what people behind your back
saying that's a flippant leader man I
respect that guy that guy gets things
done that girl gets things done
those guys get things done and then you
have that pride to say I did something
my life so the next time you hear about
automation a I complete different
perspective what can you do to have
automation and AI work in your favor for
you to become smarter wiser better with
new skills so you can have an edge in a
marketplace so the next opportunity that
comes up you can pivot and boom another
rags to riches story you not somebody
you read about in Forbes magazine I'm
talking about you your story that's what
this whole thing is really all about
so don't let them fool you don't be
naive keep your ears open your eyes open
and go do your own research and then
come to full conclusion don't even
believe me go do your own research based
on what I'm saying say Pat you're wrong
great go do your own research about it
but don't say just because I offended
you or you're hurt because I called you
out on something do something about it
anyways having said that have a killer
week this week take everybody bye-bye
you